to some he was the very embodiment of
evil the psychopathic
incarnation of the devil himself to
others he was a god-fearing defender of
the faith courageously standing up to
the feared Ottoman Empire in his time he
was known as Vlad the Impaler thanks to
his favorite method of executing people
today though we remember him as the
real-life inspiration for Bram Stoker's
infamous Prince of Darkness
in this week's biographic Swee discover
the gruesome truth about the real lad
Dracula
[Music]
Vlad the fur Dracula future Prince of
Wallachia was born in either November or
December of 14 31 in the northern
Romanian state of willle here
his father vlad ii was to become ruler
of Wallachia in the year of his second
son's birth Vlad senior joined the
Knightly society known as the order of
the Dragon
upon his induction he was given the
surname drakul which is a derivative of
Drac meaning dragon in ancient romanian
however in the modern romanian language
this means devil his son was given the
name for son of Draco that being Dracula
the world that Vlad was born into it was
a violent one consumed with disputes
over territory and rulership family name
and honor were the most important thing
something which was drummed into the boy
from the start he also understood that
the goal was to push the boundaries of
the Empire regardless of the cost the
order of the Dragon which Vlad Seanie
became a part of was committed to
defending Christianity against the hated
Ottoman Turks at the time of his son's
birth vlad ii served as a guard
commander in the mountain passes in will
asia we don't actually know who Vlad's
mother was when Vlad was born his father
was married to Princess Anne a Jew but
he also had a string of mistresses than
anyone could have given birth to the
future Dracula
Vlad's formative years were spent in
cities awara when his father ascended to
the throne of will a here in 1436 he
brought Vlad and his younger brother
Radu to live in the royal court in the
capital the boys would have been
educated at home by Greek and Roman
scholars who their father had brought in
from Constantinople they would have
busied themselves with learning the
rudiments of mathematics geography
science and languages including old
Church Slavonic German and Latin but
they're privileged upbringing was rudely
interrupted when their father was ousted
as ruler by a rival group who were in
league with the Hungarians
blad senior built an alliance with the
ottomans who agreed to help him regain
his throne on the proviso that he paid
tribute to sultan mehmed ii and that he
leave his two sons at the ottoman court
as a guarantee of his loyalty
Vlad's had no choice and the two boys
were seized and made prisoners although
relatively well treated the boys were
able to observe the Turkish use of
Teheran as an instrument in order to
achieve their ends this was something
which Vlad would use to great effect
later in his own life while in the
ottoman Court the boys were able to
further their education being instructed
in logic the Turkish language and the
teachings of the Quran they were also
given lessons in horsemanship and
warfare the two brothers differed
markedly in their attitude towards their
captivity Radley the younger brother
accepted the situation and embraced his
new life and the teachings that came
with it he would eventually convert to
Islam and into service in the Ottoman
Court Vlad
however resisted at every turn despite
constant punishment for his early
attitude with the assistance of the
Turks Vlad senior was able to regain his
throne but this wasn't something that
lasted in 1447 Hungarian backed rebels
attacked again forcing Vlad and his
oldest son
Mircea ii to flee both were eventually
captured and put to death the next in
line to the throne of Wilaya was Vlad
the thirds older brother but he had
become a monk and lived in a monastery
this left Vlad who is now 16 as the
rightful heir to the throne
despite his obstinacy the Turks had
grown fond of the teenager they vowed to
help him regain his throne which they
did with an overthrow of the rebel ruler
in 1448
as soon as the Ottomans left however the
Hungarians were back and within two
months Vlad was forced to flee to
Moldova for the next three years he
lived there under the protection and
tutelage of his uncle Prince Bogdan the
second
but when Bogdan was assassinated in 1451
Vlad again fled this time along with his
cousin Prince Steven the two young men
ended up in Transylvania where they came
under the mentorship of a Hungarian
warrior named John Hunyadi he was a
power broker who was fiercely opposed to
the Ottoman Empire and yadi had
originally supported the new ruler of
Malaya a man by the name of vladislav ii
but the relationship it quickly
disintegrated this was thanks largely to
vadas Slavs appeasement of the Turks
when vladislav invaded and burned
several villages in Transylvania who
Yardies patients it simply gave out he
looked the young blasts to take back the
throne that rightfully belonged to him
in the same year 1453 the Holy Roman
city of Constantinople fell to the
Ottoman Turks it now appeared as if the
whole of Europe was theirs for the
taking
the securing of will akeya became more
important than ever and in 1456 Vlad led
an army into the area he mets the army
of vladislav from the field of battle
and ended up killing the usurper in
hand-to-hand combat with the death of
vladislav vlad was restored to power as
the ruler of Wallachia over the next six
years he would rule with an
unprecedented bloodlust that would
cement his name forever in the annals of
merciless monix
[Music]
having secured the throne of will a Kia
for himself Vlad sent a portion of his
army over the border to help his cousin
Stephen to secure the throne of Moldova
when this was accomplished the two
cousins held sway over a large swath of
the Balkans proving a powerful
stronghold against the Turks Vlad now
set his mind on revenge
he had his spies go and find the names
of any Nobles who had even been remotely
involved in the plot to overthrow his
father having collected a list of names
Vlad invited the men to an Easter feast
along with their families but as soon as
the traitors arrived they were arrested
the order among them were impaled then
and there right in front of their
families those who were younger were
forced into slavery laboring to rebuild
Vlad's castle when this job was done
they they were all killed
Vlad's treatment of the traitors to his
father's reign it was just the beginning
he next proceeded to enforce his own
stringent moral code on the entire
population any deviation was met with
unthinkable cruelty he seemed to be
especially concerned with female
chastity any woman who lost her
virginity prior to marriage or who
defiled the marriage bed would be
impaled with the insertion point being
the vagina more often than not their
breasts would also be cut off with a man
with whom they had committed fornication
being forced to eat them Vlad also had a
hatred of beggar's considering them to
be existing off the hard work of others
it is said that he once invited all the
beggars in will a Kia to a massive feast
in a centrally located wooden Hall once
they had eaten to their full he is said
to have ordered the doors bolted in the
building set on fire in this way he is
said to have rid his realm of the
scourge of poverty
on the international scene the Ottoman
threats was becoming more ominous in
1460 poke past the second held a
Congress of Mantua in Italy
calling for a new crusade to reclaim
Constantinople and push the Ottomans
back to the desert the crusade was to
last for three years and will be led by
Matias Corvinus he was the son of John
Hunyadi who had been killed during an
invasion of Serbia Matias made a tour of
European kingdoms seeking support for
the enterprise the only ruler who gave a
positive response was Vlad Dracula of
will a here determines to hold his
kingdom safe from the Turks he formed an
alliance with Matthias Corvinus the
Ottomans meanwhile were aware of the
lack of support for this new crusade
sultan mehmed ii seized the advantage by
capturing the last independent serbian
city Smederevo during this campaign the
hungarian general mehar leases lagy was
taken captive this general was known to
vlad having helps put down a revolt in
1548 when vlad heard that he had been
sawed in half his blood boiled and he
became more committed than ever to
teaching the ottomans a lesson that they
would never forget the Ottoman Empire
extended to Greece in 1461 when the weak
ruler surrendered without putting up any
defense
now both Corinth and the capital of
maestra were ruled by the Turks the
Sultan also had his sights on will Asia
he declared it to be part of the Ottoman
Empire as such she sent envoys to Vlad's
castle in order to collect a tribute of
ten thousand ducats along with 500 men
to be taken into the Turkish army but
the Sultan had underestimated the young
ruler
when the Sultan's envoy's refused to
lift their turbans as a sign of respect
to him
Vlad became enraged and had his gods
drive nails through their turbans and
into their skulls the incredulous Sultan
responded by sending his army across the
Danube in order to seize the men and
bring them back to become a part of his
army Vlad sent his forces to the area to
grab any tax that could be found they
were soon impaled on red-hot stakes
towards the end of 1461 Vlad wrote to
the Sultan informing him that he could
not afford to pay a tribute but that he
was coming to Constantinople and was
ready to negotiate Mac med was a where
Vlad had already aligned himself with
the crusade so he decided to take the
relay he and ruler who had dared to
murder his n voice by force he sent one
of his generals along with a thousand
strong cavalry to meet with Vlad with
the intention of ambushing him but Vlad
got wind of the plan and put into
operation his own ambush as the
approaching Turks were negotiating their
way through a narrow Traverse Vlad and
his army they attacked it has been
reported that Vlad's attack was one of
the first instances where gunpowder was
used apparently to deadly effect the
Turks were killed with many of them
suffering of lads favourite torture and
that was of course in payment with his
blood now up Vlad took his army across
the Danube River where they attacked
Ottoman controlled areas in Bulgaria
between Serbia and the Black Sea Vlad
would go in advance to fortify towns and
use his skills in the Turkish language
to encourage the guards to open the
gates then his army would pour in from
over the horizon that we're then go into
a killing frenzy slaughtering every
Turkish man woman or child but he could
find over a period of two weeks he led
his army over an area of 500 miles
killing around 23,000 people in February
at 1462 Vlad wrote in glowing terms to
Matthias Corvinus about what he had
accomplished I read I have killed
peasant men and women young and dolls
who lived a table citizen and novice a
low where the Danube flows into the sea
up to rahova which is located near Julia
from the lower danube to such places of
Sam of it and Guillen
we killed twenty three thousand eight
hundred and eighty four Turks without
counting those in
burned in homes of the Turks whose heads
were cut by our soldiers
thus your highness you must know I've
broken the peace an outraged Sultan
ordered his Grand Vizier Mac mud with
18,000 troops to destroy a port in well
a Kea called Brailler
this force was intercepted by Vlad and
his thirty thousand strong army the
Turks were utterly defeated with only
8000 of them surviving these quickfire
victories garnered Vlad a heroic
reputation throughout Europe even the
Pope praised him at the same time his
reputation as the Impaler King served to
intimidate the Turkish people many of
whom flared the European part of the
Ottoman Empire for Anatolia in response
to the slaughter in the fear that Vlad
had caused amongst his people Sultan
Mehmed abandoned his campaign in Greece
and turned his full attention to the
Vlad problem he gathered an army of a
hundred fifty thousand people with the
sole mission of finding and killing Vlad
the Sultan had already promised the
rulership of will a Kiat of lands
younger brother Radu with himself at the
head the Sultan set out to find and kill
Vlad the Impaler
Vlad's force of around 30,000 were not
only hugely outnumbered they were also
hopelessly outclassed as far as weaponry
was concerned they carried only Lance's
and daggers whereas the Turks had in
their midst squadrons of deadly archers
along with powerful siege and missile
weaponry despite this Vlad was able to
inflict major casualties upon the
Sultan's forces he followed a scorched
earth policy as he moved away from the
approaching Turks wells were poisoned
with entire populations including
animals being evacuated
Vlad also engaged in guerrilla fighting
tactics hit-and-run raids were made on
the Sultan's army and as a primitive
type of germ warfare was also utilized
where men who were afflicted with the
bubonic plague or sentient Turkish towns
to infect as many people as possible the
tactic worked with the plague spreading
to the Sultan's men in the end though
the efforts of Vlad's men were no more
than an irritant to the vastly superior
Turkish army steadily they moved on
getting ever closer to Vlad's castle
when they arrived there Vlad and his
24,000 men strong army were holed up in
a mountain refuge just outside of the
city that who was now faced with an
encirclement by the Turks which would
eventually force his army into
starvation did something quite
extraordinary even for him leaving his
men behind in the mountains he disguised
himself and walked directly into the
Turkish army encampments he quickly
determines the position of the Sultan's
tent he found out that the Sultan had
given the order for his men to remain in
their tents at night in order to prevent
panic in the event of an attack he then
quietly slipped out of the camp and
returned back to his own men
Vlad's now set about planning a surprise
attack on the Sultan's army it was his
personal intention to enter the Sultan's
tent and drive a knife through meknes
heart on the night of June the 17th 1462
he divided his forces into two and then
attacked from both the North and the
South the Turks were caught off guard
allowing the attackers to inflict heavy
losses within an hour of savage fighting
more than 15,000 Turks were slaughtered
at a cost of some five thousands of
Vlad's men he himself succeeded in
entering the tents that he had
previously picked out the only problem
was that he had selected the wrong ten
found no sultan in sight a day break
Vlad called off the attack and his men
melted back into the mountains the
Sultan was so despondent that he pulled
back and was prepared to retreat all the
way back across the Danube however he
was convinced by his generals that
success was still within their grasp and
so he led his men into the capital city
when they arrived in Targa vishna the
Turks found an abandoned city they also
found the remains of 20,000 Turkish
soldiers killed in previous conflicts
and impaled on stakes at this site the
Sultan is said to have remarked a man
who has done such things is worth much
with nothing to do in the empty city the
Sultan installed a Radu
as the new ruler of Malaya and then
turned and began to retrace his steps
back to the Danube Radu
the younger brother of lads now take his
forces and circled Vlad's castle located
on a cliff just outside of the city
Vlad's first wife was in the castle ins
legend has it that she vowed to feed
herself to the fishes rather than fall
to the Turks
apparently she then threw herself from
the walls into the river below
Radhi now set about solidifying his
position meanwhile the Sultan had taken
his army away to Braila where the town
was destroyed and hundreds were killed
Vlad knew that he had to regroup and
gather a larger force if he was to have
any chance regaining control of Malaysia
he made his way to Hungary where he
sought the help of his ally Matias
Corvinus Matias appeared to give his
support even making battle plans with
flat however Corvinus had secretly
turned against his old ally he organized
the plan to ambush Vlad's and the
Impaler was taken as his prisoner the
reason for Matias change of loyalty has
been debated now for centuries with the
consensus being that he wanted to become
Holy Roman Emperor and knew that an end
to hostilities with the Turks was needed
before that can become a reality
Vlad spent the next four years as a
prisoner in Hungary during this time he
converted to Catholicism he also met
King Matthias his cousin having softened
his attitude towards his prisoner Matias
allowed the two to marry apparently he
was released just prior to the ceremony
Vlad and his new wife were given a house
at pest it was under strict instructions
not to return to a lakeya yes he had no
intention of giving up on the crown that
still rightly belongs to him he secretly
collaborated with a former military
commander they managed to gather
together an army consisting of a mixture
of Hungarian Transylvanian malakian and
Moldovian forces Vlad set out with his
makeshift army in the middle of 1476 by
now his younger brother Radu had died
and had been replaced by Prince pasaba
the elder before flat had even got to
Targoviste
and his army had fled Vlad was placed on
the throne and the army largely
dissolved Vlad's was back in power but
he lacked a strong army in fact he only
had around 4,000 men to draw upon so
when the Turks returned two months after
his retaking of the throne he was
soundly defeated
the exact details surrounding Vlad's
death there are a matter of some debate
most scholars agreed that he was killed
while fighting the Turks in early 1477 a
contemporary Turkish chronicler recorded
that the Turks killed and decapitated
him sending his head back to
Constantinople there it is said to have
been preserved in honey and put on
display so that everyone could see that
the dreaded Impaler was really finally
dead it is estimated that Vlad's legacy
of execution methods included more than
20,000 impalements 5000 beheadings
10,000 burnings at stake 10 Turks who
had nails driven through their turbans
and at least one who was boiled alive
and then cannibalized yes in his home
country of Romania Vlad is seen as a
hero he is an important national figure
a god-fearing stalwart who stood up to
the Ottoman Empire well I guess it all
depends on your perspective so I really
hope you enjoyed their video if you did
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel for brand new biographies every
Monday and every Thursday also I've got
another channel it's called today I
found out it's sort of like bio graphics
but way more broad on that channel we
get deep into all of the details on all
sorts of interesting stuff check it out
through the link on the screen now but
if you're looking for something else to
watch right now why not check out a
biography from the archives or if today
I found our video over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching